[Music]
the best SUV that you can buy right now
just happens to be Electric
okay that's probably that's a pretty
controversial statement let's let's
let's zoom out a little bit with uh
maybe something we can all agree on like
electric cars are really expensive right
now that's just a fact I think we can
all be on the same page about like there
are basically no really really good but
also really really cheap electric cars
but that's not for a lack of trying like
they all know that that would kill like
a twenty thousand dollar Tesla would do
amazing people would love to buy that
that's just not something that's
possible with the prices and the The Way
businesses work right now so when I
start just with the best SUV that you
can buy happens to be electric that's
actually a strategy
let's zoom out a little bit so gas cars
have been evolving as you know they've
been maturing for years and years and
then now this suddenly very new and very
expensive technology comes along that is
an electric drivetrain with a huge
battery and so if you're a company
that's going to add it to your car it
will become a more expensive car so if
you're a car company knowing that you
want to start making electric vehicles
you have a very specific choice to make
and we get to like follow this in real
time and see them all try to do this and
that choice is do you want to compete at
the highest end to be the best possible
product or do you want to compete at the
lowest end on price and of course
business 101 if you've looked at these
graphs long enough you can understand
that it just makes more business sense
to try now when the technology is
expensive to compete on the highest End
by just trying to make the best overall
thing a no-brainer better product and
then you know in the future when
hopefully the price of the tech gets
lower we can also get those that are
competing on price that's why you're
seeing cars that are expensive and
electric and not a lot of cheap electric
cars I mean there are some but they're
more expensive than their gas
counterparts so they don't really make
sense so I guess then that brings us to
the question is the rivion r1s
the best SUV in the world is it the best
one you can buy
well it makes a pretty compelling case
and I think it's really good so if
you've heard me talk about the truck
before the rivien r1t well then the name
r1s makes a lot of sense because the
front half is also R1 it's basically the
same but the back half it trades the
truck bed and the gear tunnel for a
third row and all the benefits that come
with a third row SUV form factor so
literally like if one of these pulled up
behind you from this angle you could not
tell if that was the truck or the SUV
that just pulled up behind you because
it's identical and two come to the side
and you see the differences now I've
been driving this brand new Limestone
colored r1s with the dark all-terrain
wheels for about a week now it's been
really solid and I'm not even going to
highlight the front stuff because it's
basically the same if you've seen the
video go back and watch the r1t video
it's the same truck it's the same
interior not a lot interesting here so
let's just do the part that's different
now so let's take a look at the new uh
and slightly improved interior I'm in
the second row right now it's not as
gigantic of a second row as like a
Escalade or something gigantic like that
but in a lot of its competition a lot of
other three row SUVs perfectly
reasonable and then behind me is the two
seats of this seven seater which is
smaller it's it's better for kids I
wouldn't want to be back there for a
road trip but it's fine it's comfortable
you've got three kids this is the type
of thing in the US you see a lot of and
they've made a lot of subtle
improvements even since the r1t that I
first checked out obviously you've got
this huge glass roof up here at the top
there are slightly improved better
speakers so the Meridian sound system
that was in the previous one was fine
actually was really good these I imagine
are in roughly the same locations around
the cabin but they sound way better and
then still material choices are great
and there are events everywhere really
solid builds nothing's creaking or
scratching or squeaking or anything like
that this is this is nice but of course
since it's three rows you want to know
how to get back to the third row so so
let's do that so there's a nice little
button on the shoulder of the seat you
press that it slides It Forward on these
rails and you can just pop right back
here into the back seat so look as
predicted not a ton of leg room that's
the seat right there but you do have the
vents back here you also do have
additional sunroof behind this little
pillar here which feels pretty nice and
you still have the entire trunk behind
you spacious Airy at the light interior
color helps of course but yeah that's
the third row you didn't get with the
r1t got a little cup holder back here
there's a speaker over here the vents
that you can point at yourself and of
course on the other side same deal but I
do want to show you the trunk space
because I think that's what's the most
important actually impressive so of
course coming around to the back you
still have that distinctive light bar
across you still have the blinkers on
either side but now if you want to open
this lift gate here it automatically
will pop open like that which kind of
reminds me I think a Jeep Wagoneer or
something does this but you've got this
sort of split gate the top half opens
the bottom half stays closed so if
you've got stuff sort of uh rolling
around in here it's protected it'll stay
in then this button right here will pop
this section down and it's got this
little clever mechanism here that
creates this sort of flat surface as it
slides open so now you can slide things
in here and if you even want you can use
these locking and unlocking bits here
that can slide around lock into place
and then tie things down to the other
side so if you've got something that's
actually going to stick out the back and
you don't have enough room that can help
you out now I mentioned there's no gear
tonal but they even kept things like
what you find in the truck bed which is
1500 watts of power and you also have
your air compressor back here so all
that's still good you still get to keep
it there's also this giant subwoofer on
the other side but of course if this is
going to be the best thriller SUV it's
got to do better than this right I mean
all the seats are up that's fine for
groceries I guess but you already know
it's electric so that means there's even
more space where there wouldn't be a gas
tank that's your first aid kit this is I
believe a charging kit or Tire
compressor yep air compressor and then
even more sub trunk space but just go
ahead and pull this up real quick and
you'll find an even more gigantic area
underneath where you could put a spare
if you had one but you don't so you just
have a ton more space where you put
groceries that won't slide around and
all of that is closable and hideable
under this flat surface but I do think
it's time to put the seats down just so
you can see how ridiculous it gets when
you put all that space down actually
this is kind of a sweet setup for me if
I don't have all the seats needed at
once this is a sort of a giant flat area
where you can fit a ton of stuff I'll
try to put numbers on the screen if
there are any available to sort of
contextualize how much that is and then
of course I can't reach from back here
but you've got the buttons to pop the
last two all the way down I don't know
why the headrests don't go down but when
they do go down it's just this gigantic
massive amount of space you could fit a
bike or two back here and still have the
front seats it's it's pretty sick so
does having enough space for a mattress
folded down make it the best SUV in the
world
not by itself no I mean the sub trunk
space is great you also can't forget
about the front trunk which the r1t also
had and all the power tool stuff and all
the space and the green roof and
oh yeah and then you gotta drive it of
course spoiler alert this one's also
really fun to drive which is probably
not a shock to anyone who knew anything
about the r1t because yes this one is
also a quad motor 800 horsepower missile
in a straight line it is absurd it has
no right being this fast being seven
thousand Pounds
but it is so it is that fun again now
the difference with this in the r1t is
this one is a little bit of a shorter
wheelbase which means it does actually
feel a little bit more Nimble it does
like when I corner or when I turn around
on like a tight Road like this it does
have a smaller overall turning radius
which is great
um it also means if you're off-roading
you have a better break over angle all
these things like most people will not
use 75 of the capabilities of this
vehicle but if you do uh that'll be
really good to know but again just like
in regular driving okay I'm gonna be in
all-purpose mode because that's the
typical Mo you'll drive around in this
thing and uh it drives like as good as
any other SUV you could possibly imagine
meaning soft suspension check firm
acceleration if you want it but very
relaxed and drivable all the rest of the
time check regen great stability control
great
no problems here this is It's I I
couldn't expect much more but now you
can go into sport mode because if you're
going to spend a lot of money and you
want it to be the best overall product
you can hear the air suspension
literally lowering it as I go into the
lowest overall setting and now the
firmest most responsive mode
and it should be able to do both right
if it's going to be a super expensive
best overall product it should be able
to do both and this is maybe the only
place that I could possibly see anyone
complaining which is that it's not the
sportiest thing in the world it actually
does drive a little bit looser than the
r1t which is interesting this feels like
a suspension thing but a lot of the
accelerations and decelerations and the
way its sways a little bit back and
forward and going around turns I feel a
little bit extra swaying where I didn't
expect it you could argue that that's a
weakness of this particular vehicle sure
but in literally 99 of the cases
especially with 99 of the drivers
nobody's uh actually ever going to
notice so I've been really really
impressed and just having a lot of fun
with it I actually find I find it fine
to just be in all-purpose mode most of
the time I also don't have that much
off-roading in my daily commute or my
normal use of this vehicle so that's
also fine but if I did I would have
off-road mode snow Mode's cool to have
uh of course if I was Towing something I
could pull that off too the only thing I
really tow is a camera rig so I wouldn't
get this if I was towing a whole ton of
weight you should watch Jerry
everything's video where he actually did
test out how well it would tow actually
he had an r1t for that video
but I wouldn't get it for that either
but this just really fits the uh
that is Nimble this just fits the it
fits the adventure vehicle Mantra it
really feels like it matches that
description Adventure vehicle so it's
like all right Marquez if you're gonna
call the best what is it competing
against well if you're just going
straight six row SUV there's a lot of
them out there and America loves these
things they're the Toyota Highlanders or
the I think that's a Honda Pilot right
there that's a three row lots of things
that will all be cheaper than this
dramatically cheaper than this one I
think even the Escalade the Cadillac
Escalade will be cheaper than this
rivian r1s but what this rivian r1s does
is it's able to offer all of the things
that you want out of the vehicle like
this and doesn't really skimp so some of
those might be really comfortable and
well built
but they won't be as high tech or they
might be really high tech and well built
but they won't be as fast you see what I
mean now this is the electric one too so
it's going to be the quietest it's going
to be the most responsive the most
efficient it's going to have the most
space and those are all benefits kind of
over all of the other six seven seat
SUVs so I think if the mission is just
like make a great thing that's just the
most fun for the people who don't really
have a budget and just want to go crazy
and have the coolest best thing uh
I don't think that there's much else
that I would take over this one like if
you just pressed a button then I had
three kids and I had to daily Drive
something that could you know go get
groceries take them all to school and
just have a fun time in otherwise this
would be uh this would be pretty good
now the question for everyone else is
like okay when is this experience when
is the electric vehicle experience
that's actually fun and good going to
come down in price and that's just a
tech and a Development question keep in
mind this company also has to spend
money on building a charging Network and
all the other things they're doing with
the delivery Vans I keep seeing the
rivian delivery vans on the road all the
time because there's an Amazon Warehouse
near here so I feel like I see one like
every single day
but you know that's just one company
rivian's doing stuff Tesla's doing stuff
a bunch of other Rock Solid companies
that have been making cars for a long
time are all starting to make EVs and
develop them and spend money and lower
the price slowly but we'll eventually
get there I actually talked to the CEO
of rivian RJ on my podcast this week
I'll link it below if you want to listen
to that but we talked about the R2
platform and what that's designed to do
to be a lower priced version of this
same experience
and if they're able to accomplish that
in as short as a year from now we're
already moving in the right direction so
look I really like this thing uh whether
it's the best SUV ever or not
you know that'll be up for debate I I
really like it I've had a lot I think
people just have fun with it in general
that's pretty obvious but I am really
impressed with this first effort from
this particular company and I'm hoping
they're able to continue because r1t and
r1s really set the tone for what we can
expect from rivian in the future and
hopefully we get a bunch of other cool
EVS following in those footsteps and
lowering and price sometime
soon
please
okay
that's been it thanks for watching if
you want to watch the the podcast with
with RJ or even uh watch the autofocus
videos that I make on all kinds of other
thoughts on cars I'll leave both those
links below if you want to check them
out and I'll catch y'all in the next one
see you over there peace